bild was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich befinde mich
heute hier wieder im wohnzimmer wie ihr
sehen könnt irgendwie muss ich sagen
finde ich das hier auch sehr entspannend
vor allem im hintergrund ihr könnt ja
mal sagen was wir besser findet er so im
büro
da ist alles auch noch ein bisschen
enger oder hier keine ahnung würd mich
mal interessieren auf jeden fall haben
wir euch etwas super spannendes vor
ich bin glaube ich der letzte der so ein
video machen kann einfach weil es auch
die letzte box war
ihr habt es oft gewünscht und ich habe
viele kommentare bekommen leute haben
geschrieben alex was ist macht doch mal
bitte diese mediamarkt mystery bock das
problem ist halt gewesen es hatten nur
ganz wenige märkte diese aktion ich habe
extra auch ein paar angerufen und so
weit ich weiß gab es auch immer nur 35
euro typen die hatten zwar den
dreifachen wert aber es gab nicht viele
davon durch zufall habe ich allerdings
jemanden gesehen der die auf ebay
versteigert hatte und ich habe einfach
mal angebot eingetippt die lag ihnen die
so bei 80 euro ich habe glaube ich 92
euro geboten ist schon sehr teuer aber
egal ich habe sie bekommen und ich
dachte mir für das video ist es sehr
heiß ist auch angekommen
hier ist sie drin und wir machen jetzt
mal zusammen auch ich bin ultra gespannt
werden da coole sachen drin sein ich
kannte ja natürlich auch so ein bisschen
mit den saturn boxen vergleichen von
denen ich ja schon einige ausgepackt hat
bevor wir allerdings mit der box starten
wollte ich noch weiß verlosen wir sind
hier im alex wie adventskalender
natürlich und heute passend zum thema
wird die alex wie mystery box verlost
das wäre eine box sein da werden extrem
viele dinge drin sein
viele brauchbare dinge auch eventuell
viel schreit man kann aber auch alle
sachen die man dann nicht auf eventuell
verkaufen oder so ich habe in den
letzten monaten in boxen von firmen so
viele produkte bekommen
wie werde ich da alle rein tun dass die
station im warenwert von über 56 700
euro seien also da bin ich mir sicher
hat deswegen wird sich das auf jeden
fall lohnen ihr müsst einfach nur
irgendein kommentar schreiben schreibt
bitte euren instagram namen oder
irgendeine kontaktmöglichkeit wie ich
euch halt erreichen kann da hin weil
über youtube peters nicht so leicht seid
einfach abonnent von alex wie youtube
kanal und ich werde dann in den
folgenden tagen in meiner ins all um
story auf instagram den gewinner ziehen
person zufallsgenerator und dort dann
halt den kommentar so ihr könnt das
daran sehen tut so viel dazu wir starten
jetzt mal ich hab dich schon aufgemacht
weil ich war mir nicht sicher was
was da drin sein wird ist auch mein
nachbar gewesen checkt aber auch
unbedingt die letzten videos arbeit in
den letzten videos wurden auch noch
ipads und ein iphone rausgehauen
die haben noch keinen gewinner also da
kann man noch mitmachen so sagt ich habe
übrigens keine hose an gerade vielleicht
hat man das gerade gesehen okay das
sieht doch schon mal ja die kann man
noch lesen überraschungstüte warenwert
103 eur 66 ach so gekauft für 33 euro
kann man hier sehen also ungefähr den
dreifachen warenwert ich habe mich dazu
gewundert weil hinten steht
verpackungshersteller aus der
jägerstraße 173 in köln das war einfach
eine straße weiter von der wohnung
entfernt wo ich in köln halt gewohnt
habe so klein ist die welt na ja dann
müssen wir das jetzt irgendwie auf
kriegen das ist schon gut verpackt das
wollte zusammen gepackt hat war dass da
mal gefährlich alter hier sind jetzt
überall diese also ich muss sagen diese
typen finde ich ultra geil alles meins
alles muss raus steht darauf
ich weiß sind das vielleicht einfach
standard typen von media markt keine
ahnung ich dachte ich du irgendwas von
überraschungstüte drauf leider nicht ja
gut dann ist es jetzt doch nicht dann
ist es jetzt noch nichts besonderes aber
aber im ersten eindruck ist es halt
neisser als einfach nur sonne stumpfen
karton von saturn zu bekommen mit
bisschen saturn klebeband rauke starten
einfach mal rein ich wundere mich gerade
ein bisschen weil die das ist einfach
das ist einfach genau der gleiche hellen
warum auch immer hier jetzt einen helm
drin ist wie dieser helm den ich schon
mal in einer saturn works drin hatte
also kann man sagen diese safety kidney
weder bei media markt noch bei saturn
irgendwie gut aber naja
das ding ist nämlich in der alex wie
mystery box die dann verlost wird ist
dieses ganze set schon einmal drin und
ich hatte auch hier von vielen sachen
halt noch da reingepackt genauso wenig
wie diese weste
naja und wahrscheinlich auch noch dieses
zeug hier ja das ist halt jetzt sehr
schade weil an sich hat das mal 60 euro
kostet im laden ich hab das ja alles er
googelt aber aktuell kann man dieses
klingen für 16 euro im internet kaufen
weswegen das von einem flop ist da habe
ich mir jetzt mehr oh wir haben was von
apple
ja das ist ja ein witz das ist alles was
wir haben hier ein vga adapter und jetzt
haltet euch fest wie ipad iphone und
ipod touch das ist einfach noch die seit
ganz alte anschluss der hier in die
ipads eine entschuldigung nicht in das
ipad aber in dieses ipad rein passt ja
das sind ja zum beispiel die ipads 2 die
ich letztens bestellt habe davon habe
ich ziemlich viele
da kann man das jetzt zum beispiel
anschließen also da wirklich als kleine
nachricht an media markt ist es euer
ernst was soll man da noch bei saturn
waren wenigstens sachen drin die man
gebrauchen kann
geile sachen und das hier kann mir
keiner erzählen dass das doch irgendwie
wert wir werden die sachen am ende alle
zusammen rechnen und schauen dann mal
wir machen weiter hier mit und hier
haben wir ein ultra dünnen profifoto uv
filter von rola rola ist eine marke die
machen viele kameras auch viele action
camps das ist so die action camps sind
oftmals gar nicht schlecht das ist dann
gopro abklatsch und die kosten hat dann
nur 100 euro
aber was ich jetzt hier mit soll weiß
ich nicht habe ich auch absolut keine
verwendung für aber legen wir einfach
mal zur seite dann machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten produkt und hier wird es
jetzt ganz verrückt alltag also ok auf
dem ersten eindruck sieht es aus wie
papa aber es ist desinfektionsmittel für
die hände muss ich sagen es bis jetzt
auf jeden fall das basta aktuell aus dem
ganzen paket denn was man daneben und
machen weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
als nächstes haben wir hier ein okay das
finde ich sogar gar nicht mal schlecht
ein usb stick 8 gb ja muss ich sagen
dann kann ich zum beispiel selber ganz
gut gebrauchen dann mache ich auch mal
auf der wird dann an ihr gewinn von euch
raus gehauen
der ist als ziemlich klein gehalten und
das finde ich sehr nice kannst du sie in
dein macbook stecken oder so und da was
drauf ziehen weil manchmal sind
usb-sticks wirklich absolut unumgänglich
sein wenn man mal schnell daten zwischen
dem apple gerät und einem windows-pc
austauschen muss oder so da brauche ich
auf usb sticks deswegen behalte ich den
safe weitergeht
mit dieser sache hier haben wir eine
projekte folie sondern panzerglas folie
kannst du auf dein ja ich glaube das
sieht aus als wäre das fürs
wenn wir auf jeden fall unten noch
diesen button ich denke mal fürs iphone
8 was kostet das 23 euro vielleicht fünf
euro keine ahnung aber an sich auch
jetzt nicht wirklich geil vorerst aber
wieder kommentare kommen mit alex voll
undankbar leute da muss ich sagen das
kann ich wirklich nicht verstehen weil
wenn hier draufsteht warenwert 103 euro
und wir wissen jetzt hier diese ausbeute
haben ist es wirklich ein witz
okay was ist das denn selbstklebend
säurefrei herr kay das mache ich mal auf
ach so foto kleber damit kann man fotos
ach so ja diese dinge kennt man ja
eigentlich oder kannst du ganz entspannt
fotos in einem fotoalbum kleben oder ein
kühlschrank wo auch immer ich habe in
meiner wohnung gar keine fotos hängen
aber diese dinger werde ich einfach mal
aufbewahren weil irgendwas kann man die
immer gut gebrauchen
deswegen werde ich zumindest eine
packung davon selbst behalten vielleicht
kommt die andere ja auch noch ins alexy
mastery pakete und dann schauen wir mal
eine sache haben wir noch hey also ein
weg mund nasen was die zehn stück ohne
witz dass hier eigentlich alles außer
den usb stick und vielleicht das hier
und dieses case und die hülle würde man
doch nicht bei media markt erwarten oder
was hat das sind bitte mit einem
elektrofachhandel zu tun überhaupt gar
nicht und dann waren die das hier in die
boxen schreiben drauf 103 euro waren wir
am schalter haben wir noch was aber es
geht ja ob es geht ja noch weiter moment
mal
entschuldigung ich hab mich ich habe
mich zu weit aus dem fenster gelehnt
vielleicht bis jetzt hier haben wir
wieder so eine schutzfolie für einen
samsung galaxy a7 und hierfür ein qa
weil die smart ten leid
ok und jetzt sehe ich hier der absolut
neueste schrei flaute wireless ach so ok
hier haben wie wireless kopfhörer zum
joggen die kannst du dir so umlegen
dann fallen nämlich runter und hier
steht drauf die halten bis zu sieben
stunden also das ist bis jetzt
eigentlich das beste was wir drin haben
und zu guter letzt sind es dann hier
noch was ist das denn eine kassette
druck werden denn heutzutage noch
kassetten verkauft also als kind hatte
ich immer kassetten so eine ganze riesen
sammlung bibi und tina benjamin blümchen
ein koffer war das aber das ist schon
ein bisschen was her und jetzt habe ich
hier eine musikkassette sound master
audio kassette ich weiß nicht vielleicht
wird das ja noch irgendwie in tonstudios
verwendet oder so kein plan stelle ich
einfach mal daneben und das ist es dann
jetzt aber wirklich gewesen die ganze
tüte ist leer
wir haben jetzt insgesamt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 des damals 19
zehn produkte zehn produkte waren drin
und ohne witz ich glaube nicht dass das
50 euro übersteigen wird
wir schauen mal eben da also der usb
stick klar sind nur acht gigabyte kostet
hier vier euro 89 hier sogar drei euro 9
er gut diese kopfhörer kosten
tatsächlich zwischen 25 und 34 euro 99
das hätte ich eigentlich gar nicht mal
gedacht er es dass sie haben wir 16 euro
dass hiermit auch nicht viel kosten drei
euro
die hier haben eigentlich gar keinen
wert 16 euro plus 4 euro sind 20 euro
plus 30 euro sind 50 euro dann haben wir
die hier noch sagen war die a2 eur 53
euro dass ihr kostet auch nichts dass
sie können sind auch nichts sagen 55
euro das hat keinen wert mehr
das hier kostet ein ich würde sagen
insgesamt sind wir hier bei circa 60
euro warenwert und garantiert nicht 103
euro diese 103 euro ist vielleicht der
wert den media markt irgendwann mal für
diese produkte bezahlt hat aber dann
kann ich auch genauso gut sagen dieses
ipad 2 hat vor acht jahren mal 700 euro
gekostet und deswegen würde ich dafür
700 euro haben schade gewesen aber ich
habe es versucht ich hoffe das video an
euch gefallen lasse mir super gerne doch
nach oben da und wir sehen uns dann
übermorgen wieder gibt's neues geiles
video abonniert sehr gern den kanal und
checkt auf meinen anderen kanal auf alex
da kommen aktuelle maxi life stories und
irgendwelche geschichten sowie action
mäßig das war es von mir
haut rein